bonjour le président giscard d'estaing
partira cet après midi pour le fort de
brégançon le chef de l'état va prendre
quelques jours de vacances le
gouvernement aussi mais aujourd'hui il y
avait le dernier conseil des ministres
avant ces mini vacances alors nous irons
bien sûr tout à l'heure à l'elysée en
compagnie de jacques hébert d'abord
voyons les titres de l'actualité
aujourd'hui les obsèques nationales qui
se prépare en italie pour les 78
victimes de l'attentât de bologne les
américains qui s'interrogent toujours
sur le bill gate est sur la bonne foi du
président carter et puis en france
l'institut pasteur qui a mis au point
quelque chose de très important un
vaccin contre une maladie redoutable
l'hépatite b
nous parlerons de tout cela nous verrons
aussi des images de la 3e journée du
championnat de football et des images
d'un meeting d'athlétisme a remis hier
soir où philippe houillon a sauté 5
mètre soixante dix à la perche vignerons
étaient présents fils vignerons pardon
vignerons étaient très en forme
malheureusement il était en forme une
semaine trop tard alors commençons par
l'actualité internationale avec une
réaction du ministère français des
affaires étrangères après l'accusation
grave lancé hier soir sur tf1 par le
président iranien monsieur bani sadr
monsieur banny ça je vous le rappelle a
affirmé que des centres d'entraînement
existait en france pour préparer des
activités subversives en iran c'est une
nouvelle étape dans la campagne anti
française menée en ce moment en iran
alors écoutez la réaction du ministre
français des affaires étrangères
monsieur jean françois poncet qui
sortait de l'elysée il ya quelques
minutes
les déclarations que j'ai lus sont
dénuées de tout fondement
elles font allusion à l'existant sur les
territoires français deux camps
d'entraînement qui n'existe pas je
voudrais simplement ajouté que quoi
qu'il arrive le gouvernement ne tolérera
l'installation d'aucun équipement de ce
genre quelles que puissent en être les
utilisateurs il est évident que c'est
contraire au principe que la france
applique un ces matières
aucun démenti catégorique à l'instant de
monsieur jean françois poncet l'italie
maintenant de véritables funérailles
nationales auront lieu cet après-midi
pour les victimes du massacre de bologne
en italie toujours traumatisé par cette
affaire et l'on attend cet après midi
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
aux obsèques qui seront conduites par le
président italien sandro pertini sur
place michel en fond le pour tf journée
de deuil national en italie à 17 heures
cet après-midi la vie du pays arrêtera
tous les magasins et les cures en
fermeront leurs portes pendant que les
trois chaînes de télévision et les
radios transmettant les cérémonies se
dérouleront à la cathédrale san pedro à
nyon sur le parvis et sur la grand-place
de bologne la piazza maggiore coeur de
la cité vous tendre cinquante mille
personnes au moins sont attendus mais il
n'y aura que sept cercueils au lieu des
79 correspondant au nombre total des
victimes la plupart des familles ont
refusé les trikes l'adel offertes par
les pouvoirs publics
et pour plusieurs dirigeants politiques
nous avons rencontré ce matin
cela traduit parfaitement le sentiment
de désaffection tu gagnes la population
italienne à la suite des innombrables
attentats et massacres perpétrés depuis
onze ans on craint même des incidents ce
soir à bologne alors que le président de
la république persie ni le président du
conseil paul bigard la plupart des
ministres et dirigeants politiques
seront présents quelques groupes
validateurs essaieront canton de
transformer la douleur de la foulée
d'une manifestation de colère contre un
gouvernement efficace dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
deuxième gros titres de l'actualité
internationale un titre qui est plutôt
une interrogation ce matin jimmy carter
at il oui ou non perdu toute chance
d'être le candidat démocrate pour les
élections américaines sa contre attaque
dans la sphère du bill gate les
explications qu'il a données hier pour
tenter de prouver sa bonne foi ont-elles
convaincu les américains à washington
dominique bromberger la presse
américaine l'intérêt c'est dé a tourné
vers la convention de new york pour
laquelle j mee caster apparaît désormais
news armenia 40 par exemple en appel
téléphonique conférence de presse 84 et
et en faveur du président apparaît donc
débarrassé au moins momentanément et est
de nouveau les analyses de presse font
ressortir qu'il devrait logiquement
l'emporter pire à la convention le
washington post
elle également que confuse de sénateurs
de la commission d enquête se demande
là vous est à la peine de continuer
cette investigation l'iphone carter est
toujours à la merci d'une jeune star
révélée a le moins disant peut-être
après un mois encore ou plutôt une image
que vous allez voir sur les préparatifs
des élections américaines john anderson
le troisième homme celui qui pourrait
créer la surprise poursuit sa campagne
une campagne difficile où l'on a pu
assister vous allez le voir une scène
étonnante le candidat aux élections
américaines qui reçoit des oeufs en
pleine figure
tu as été un peu la panique dans les
services de sécurité c'était hier à
denver et vous voyez avec quelle force
le service de sécurité méprise celui qui
avait osé jeter un oeuf à la tête de
monsieur anderson mais l'incident s'est
reproduit quelques minutes plus tard au
moment où monsieur anderson prenait la
parole
pour moi
voilà une campagne plutôt difficile vous
le voyez voyons maintenant la suite de
l'actualité avec daniel duigou et bien
cette période de vacances on reparle de
plus en plus de feux de forêts
malheureusement sans que ces derniers
atteignent les proportions de ceux de
l'année dernière près de grasse
cependant trois nouveaux foyers se sont
déclarés hier soir et en ardèche 80
hectares ont été détruits mais
j'apprends à l'instant que cet incendie
vient d'être maîtrisé de nouveaux
attentats à l'explosif en corse l'un
contre un bar l'autre contre un
transformateur électrique
et puis ce matin un conseil des
ministres avant que le gouvernement
prenne aussi quelques jours de vacances
nous rejoignons jacques hébert en direct
à l'élise wii est d'abord trois moments
forts dans ces deux conseils des
ministres est d'abord une communication
sur l'aide aux populations victimes de
la famille de la famine en ouganda et
bien le président la république
française a fait une déclaration ce
matin en conseil des ministres il a dit
je cite la france va apporter son aide
aux malheureuses populations du nord de
l'ouganda directement par l'envoi de
vivres et de médicaments et
indirectement par l'aide aux
organisations caritatives notamment
françaises qui conduisent une action
remarquable et valéry giscard d'estaing
a ajouté je demande au ministre de la
défense de prévoir le stationnement sur
place de deux hélicoptères et de leurs
équipages pour permettre l'acheminement
direct des secours alors ces secours et
bien il s'agit de l'envoi de trois mille
tonnes de céréales de la mise en place
d'un hôpital de campagne et de l'envoi
aussi deux médicaments d'urgence
deuxième thème important de ce conseil
il concerne les personnes âgées et la
politique du maintien à domicile de ces
personnes âgées pour éviter de les
regrouper dans les hôpitaux dans les
hospices ou dans les maisons de retraite
et bien un chiffre significatif il ya
dix ans l'âge moyen des entrées en
maison de retraite était de 70 ans
aujourd'hui cet âge moyen est de 80
alors des efforts seront faits encore en
ce qui concerne les soins à domicile et
les départs en vacances des personnes
âgées
l'objectif nous a dit le porte parole de
l'elysée est de passer de 280 2000 à 340
mille personnes âgées assisté en est
maintenant troisième communication elle
concerne les circulaires administratives
pour jean marie poirier le porte parole
de l'elysée il s'agit de décisions
draconiennes le site est symbolique et
bien le nombre de circulaire envoyée par
les ministères aux préfectures sera
ramenée
de 3000 à 1000 par en ceci pour éviter
l'afflux de paperasserie inutile qui
arrive dans chaque préfecture alors un
exemple significatif
il y à l'heure actuelle 12 circulaire
qui arrivent par jour sur le bureau d'un
préfet et bien pour simplifier le
travail de lecture et de compréhension
de ces circulaires et bien maintenant le
préfet ne sera heureux recevra pas plus
de quatre circulaires maximum par jour
sur son bureau des circulaires qui
devront être obligatoirement signé par
le ministre pas de conseils vous le
disiez donc pas de conseil des ministres
mercredi prochain et mercredi en 15 le
prochain conseil aura lieu le 27 août à
moins que le président soit obligé de
rentrer à paris pour tenir un conseil de
manière exceptionnelle valéry giscard
d'estaing qui par cet après midi à
brégançon dans le var pour prendre
quelques jours de repos
c'est officiel le pape jean paul ii se
rendra du 15 au 19 novembre prochain en
allemagne fédérale occasion sera le
septième centenaire de la mort de saint
albert le grand le cyclone allen le
premier cyclone de la saison poursuit sa
course après avoir dévasté les caraïbes
il se dirige maintenant vers porto rico
où la jamaïque en prenant de plus en
plus de force la vitesse des vents
atteint maintenant 240 km/heure saint
vincent les grenadines la dominique et
surtout celui ci commence à réparer les
dégâts qui ont été très importants ya
soir à new york les étudiants iraniens
qui avaient été arrêtées lors d'une
manifestation ont été libérés les
autorités américaines ont en effet
vérifier qu'ils étaient bien en
situation légale aux états unis au
salvador la violence continue les corps
nus de 32 personnes ont été découverts
hier dans différents endroits du pays
sur eux des traces de torture et parmi
les corses de trois enfants de 12 à 14
ans ces personnes qui ont été
assassinées appartenait sans doute à des
mouvements de gauche
hiroshima hiroshima a célébré hier le
35e anniversaire de sa destruction par
la bombe atomique
à 8h15 l'heure à laquelle la bombe avait
plongé la ville dans le feu tous est
immobilisé train
voitures usines le maire d'hiroshima
monsieur takayama qui a demandé la
réunion d'une conférence mondiale sur la
paix avec les états unis et l'urss un
pas important vient d'être fait en
médecine contre l'hépatite la plus
redoutable l'hépatite b qui a atteint
chaque année en france au moins vingt
mille personnes
un vaccin vient d'être en effet mise au
point il sera disponible dès janvier
prochain dans les hôpitaux et les
centres médicaux
marion démarre 200 millions de personnes
dans le monde ont contacté avec ou sans
symptômes cliniques
le virus de l'hépatite b encore appelée
hépatique de la seringue
c'est donc une maladie extrêmement
répandu et de surcroît graves notamment
en comparaison de l'hépatite à à cause
des complications qu'elle peut entraîner
en effet sans parler du taux de
mortalité qui est de 0,5 à 1 %
on estime à 6 % le nombre de sujets qui
restent porteurs chroniques du virus
et parmi eux un tiers qui évolue vers
des complications hépatiques tels que la
cirrhose ou le cancer novelli se
contracte par l'intermédiaire
essentiellement de produits du sang
c'est-à-dire ans auparavant transfusion
de sang qui a sion de matériel
chirurgical mal stérilisée puis au
contact direct d'un malade parce que on
sait que le virus est éliminé par la
salive
harry wu de tête d'éternuements passe
plus ce vaccin qui concerne d'ailleurs
exclusivement l'hépatite b ne sera
disponible en pharmacie que dans deux
ans dans un premier temps seuls les
malades et les personnels hospitaliers
seront vaccinés en effet pour l'instant
la production du vaccin est encore
limitée bien qu'il ait été trouvée bien
qu'il était est trouvé il ya déjà 5 un
premier vaccin a été effectivement
réalisé par phil hope à tour est utilisé
chez du personnel des centres
d'hémodialyse
mais c'était un max à réaliser un peu
arty de artisanalement sur une petite
échelle et était nécessaire de mettre au
point une technique de production
industrielle première raison deuxième
raison c'est que
il a fallu un très long travail
d'expérimentation animale sur chappaz et
puis ensuite une année ces cliniques
très important chez l'homme pour
s'assurer que le vaccin était d'à la
fois parfaitement anodins et efficace et
aujourd'hui ce vaccin est complètement
efficaces l'expérimentation animale nous
donne de bonnes raisons de penser que ce
vaccin est très efficace expérimentation
humaine est en train de se terminer
le dépouillement aura lieu la fin du
mois et à ce voyage pourrait vous
répondre avec certitude football c'était
hier la 3e journée du championnat lille
lyon et bastia se retrouve en tête du
classement alors les principaux moments
de la journée avec didier roustan
ambiance de corrida hier soir au stade
furiani avec la venue de saint-etienne
le premier but de la partie réussie par
claude papi bastia mène 1 0 à la mi
temps après une première période
difficile saint-etienne se reprend et
égalise à la 69e minute voici l'action
lario ce pour laurent roussey 1 but
partout
ça se présente assez mal pour bastia qui
depuis la 60e minute joue à 10 paul
marchioni ayant été expulsé à la suite
d'une agression sur le jeune paganelli
malgré ce sérieux handicap les bleus
repassent davantage car c'est un exploit
de roger milla
score final bastia 2 saint-etienne 1
lyon monaco 6e minute coup franc pour
lyon qui avaient bu de serge chiesa 20e
minute on prend les mêmes et on
recommence
coup franc tiré but de serge chiesa 2-0
à la mi-temps pour lyon qui va se faire
remonter en l'espace de quelques mines
les blancs à l' attaque avec ricort un
gaucher qui sait se servir de son pied
droit
deux buts en trois minutes plus tard le
pied gauche de rich or pour le pied
droit de couriol regarder victor procès
rohaut préfère jouer avec sa tête cela
lui réussit assez bien de vue partout
mais lyon était trop fort hier soir qui
aida est un buteur mais également un
merveilleux mais l'heure de jeu c'est
lui qui va donner la balle de but à nico
leach victoire logique de lyon sur
monaco 3 buts à 2 la médaille d'or de la
niçoise passe 4 1 qui n'a pas porté
chance au capitaine nantais henri michel
ici sur la gauche nous sommes dans la
première minute de cette partie et nice
qui joue sur la droite du terrain va
ouvrir la marque
noguès bjekovic qui se présente seul
devant bertrand demanes rolland a bien
suivi à 0 pour nice les nantais en 89
minutes pour égaliser
c'est beaucoup plus qu'ils n'en faut et
un neuvième minute nous allons retrouver
le stoppeur rio aux avant postes
un but partout buteur d'un soir patrice
caillault a connu beaucoup de problèmes
devant son adversaire direct bjekovic le
nouveau savent encore pris le dessus sur
cette action et novès lui aussi a bien
suivi pour nice
un but de retard pour nantes à la mi
temps tout est encore possible mais
castellani marque un troisième but pour
nice
à la 63e minute cette fois c'est terminé
pour nous malgré une belle réaction en
fin de partie et un but du capitaine
henry michel à la 80e minute première
défaite du champion de france nantes
devant nice 3 buts à 2 les autres
résultats de cette soirée beaucoup de
matches nuls comme vous pouvez le
constater
notons au passage les premières
victoires de strasbourg et nancy au
classement 1er lille lyon et bastia avec
saint point auxerre et metz ont pris un
mauvais départ ces deux équipes se
partagent en effet la 19e place avec un
pouce et bien du football passons
maintenant à l'athlétisme à rome en
effet hier lors d'un meeting thierry
vigneron à passer à la perche 1 m 70 une
éclatante revanche sur ses adversaires
des jeux olympiques marie christine de
bourse
les 68 spectateurs romao - akrour
c'est thierry vigneron que les cent
mille spectateurs soviétique il affronte
et pourtant les mêmes adversaires le
champion olympique aux activités et le
soviétique bonne corps mais en
franchissant 5 mètre soixante dix au
premier essai il prenait une magnifique
revanche effacer ainsi sa modeste
prestation des choses olympique co
zinkievich retrouvait afin mettre 50
seulement et volkov lui ne parvenant à
franchir aucune hauteur au 400 mètres
l'allemand de l'ouest schmitt n'avait pu
défendre ses chances à moscou en raison
du boycott qui l'a prouvé hier que le
podium était à sa portée en battant le
champion olympique soviétique markin n
de près d'une seconde c'est de là même
qui lui avait ravi le record d'europe il
y à peine une semaine
placé au couloir 4 pietro mennea
l'enfant chéri du public mettait en jeu
son titre olympique face à l'américain
will et et aux vieilles années gilles
caisses en réalisant en 20 secondes et
un sentier meilleure performance de
l'année 2 mondiale de l'année il a
exercé tous les doutes et prouvé qu'il
était bien le meilleur
avec ou sans amérique la météo et bien
nous annonce encore du beau temps pour
aujourd'hui du soleil en effet sur la
majeure partie du pays attention au
mistral qui soufflera sur la basse
vallée du rhône
et puis demain la météo est un peu plus
pessimistes beaucoup de nuages et même
de l'appui sur la moitié nord du pays
les températures seront en baisse mais
sur la moitié sud comme vous le voyez
encore du soleil et de la chaleur
nous allons maintenant partir au soleil
avec des alsaciens qui sont allés eux à
la martinique pas pour des vacances mais
pour une étonnante cérémonie de jumelage
jumelage entre la ville de schoelcher à
la martinique et fessenheim en alsace
150 habitants de fessenheim sont allés
fêter l'événement organisé par la
fédération mondiale des villes jumelées
une fédération qui rassemble je vous le
rappelle si 1000 villes dans 80 pays du
monde
un reportage de jean paul la rivière
et
les majorettes qui défilent sous le
soleil de la martinique
ce sont des jeunes alsaciennes venus
célébrer le jumelage de leur commune
fessenheim avec la ville de schoelcher
jumelage logique et sentimental s'il en
est puisque fessenheim l'alsacienne est
le berceau de la famille de victor
schoelcher le député de la martinique
qui fit abolir l'esclavagé en 1848 et
schoelcher
la martiniquaise porte le nom de celui
qui est considéré ici comme le
bienfaiteur du genre humain
dès avant ce jumelage les habitants des
deux cités avaient tissé des liens
d'amitié par les changes d'enfants mais
la valeur du symbole a encore accentué
la chaleur de l'accueil réservé aux 170
personnes à et moi venu représenter aux
cérémonies les 2001 habitants de leur
commune
c'est un alsacien vivant dans l'île aux
fleurs depuis 25 ans est marié à une
martiniquaise qui a eu l'idée évident
après coup de ce jumelage
il s'appelle pernambuco est un ancien
des forces françaises libres et ouverts
depuis un an à schoelcher un restaurant
à l'enseigné de la cigogne d'alsace ce
jumelage pernambouc où il travaillait
depuis trois ans je tenais en se
jumelant je pense que je suis habitants
de shell cherche jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours
et comme ce com
victor schoelcher et est originaire de
fessenheim j'ai pensé que ça serait une
bonne chose de brasser les deux
provinces ensemble et l'amitié entre les
deux d'ailleurs vous avez pu constater
que c'est une réussite
tout le monde est content
monsieur le maire de fessenheim voulez
vous effraie jumelée avec des airs
commune de schoelcher oui c'est cher
voulez-vous d'être jumelée avec la
commune de fessenheim
les wallons c'est un véritable mariage
d'amour bull boigny
c'est une l'âge a dépassé le cadre
communal et il semble avoir raté le
cadre national
nous voulions continuer à mériter lève
accompli par chez le chien est développé
ces thèmes jusqu'à sa cession complète
dans la suite je crois que c'est les
populations elles mêmes qui feront la
suite qui feront l'avenir vous savez
qu'en 1981 nous aurons la réciproque à
fessenheim c'est à dire que c'est la vie
de celle cher qui sera accueillie chez
nous et nous tâcherons de faire aussi
bien j'espère qu'ils ont fait c'est chez
eux
schoelcher qui est dans la banlieue
ouest de port de france est un ancien
village de pêcheurs
depuis quelques années la commune a
connu un développement extraordinaire
puisqu'elle est aujourd'hui avec 23
mille habitants la deuxième ville de la
martinique avec ses vieilles maisons de
bois ces villes là enfoui dans la
verdure et ses chalets moderne
schoelcher est à la fois villages et
quartiers résidentiels
rien qui ressemble à fessenheim et à sa
centrale nucléaire
mais ce ne sont pas seulement les
analogies qui entraîne les
rapprochements effectués sous l'égide de
la fédération mondiale des villes
jumelées nous sommes partis de cette
idée est que le rapprochement entre les
peuples que le rapprochement entre des
régions entre des départements ne
résulte pas seulement deux d'accord de
traiter de décret de loi ou d'échangés
économiques que ceux qui comptent que
l'essentiel c'est que se crée des
relations humaines chez que s'est créé
de relations d'amitié ses relations
d'amitié
elles se sont établies tout
naturellement entre schoelcher roi
effets sont en émoi à la martinique les
alsaciens ont découvert les délices du
punch et les charmes épicé de la cuisine
créole
ils ont expérimenté aussi dans la bonne
humeur les traîtres plaisir du soleil
des caraïbes mais ils ont surtout trouvé
chez les martiniquais de schoelcher la
complicité chaleureux de citoyens qui
comme eux font partie du des provinces
françaises les plus particularistes mais
aussi les plus fidèles
voilà schoelcher fessenheim l'un des six
mille mariage de la fédération mondiale
des villes jumelées je vous propose
maintenant de parler d'un livre dont le
titre est assez surprenant vous allez
entendre il fait beau il fait beau mais
ne le répétez pas c'est un roman publié
par les éditions lattès roman de jean
pierre aumont que jacques legris a
rencontré jean perrault mondain il fait
beau mais ne le répétez pas votre
premier roman vous nous parler des
années d'hollywood 1950 entre 45 et 55
oui j'ai choisi cette époque parce que
pendant les cinq premières années ça a
été le temps des extravagances du du
grand hollywood légendaire avec des
personnages par celui hors du commun
et puis vers 50 a commencé la
dégringolade et c'était donc la période
charnière dégringolade due aux progrès
de la télévision beaucoup surtout je
dirais c'est un faux pas eu aussi
d'autres éléments tels que le
maccarthysme et la droite par les
européens oui dont vous parlez et ses
romans autobiographiques
bon il ya un peu de moi en ce sens que
je me trouvais à hollywood à cette
époque là c'est pas tout à fait moi non
plus parce que il s'agit de garçons
qu'il veut à aucun prix vers décidément
on ne peut pas dire que mon cas mais
disons que c'est un roman à clés parce
que il ya évidemment des personnages
qu'on reconnaît que j'étais ton j'étais
obligé de déguiser un peu le nom pour ne
pas avoir trop d'ennuis parce que je ne
suis pas toujours tendres mais également
beaucoup de noms célèbres
oui oui oui ce dont j du bien je
l'aurais gardé leur mon véritable c'est
écrit avec une bonne humeur
communicative merci mais en même temps
vous avez la dent dure je me suis bien
amusé en l'écrivant saget jeu là vous
c'était l'époque des grands
comment disait ton saout stars du cinéma
où il y avait les xaré puis avait
déclaré et que pensez vous de cette
expérience
cette expérience pour vous qu'elle fait
du théâtre qui avait chanté qui avait
écrit des pièces de théâtre robert ça
n'avait rien à voir le théâtre c'est ma
vie c'est ma passion
là c'était une espèce
longue récréation et je regardais ça
avec les yeux d'un jeune français qui
arriverait dans un pays compte tenu
qu'ils n'avaient aucun rapport avec le
reste de l'univers et vous en avez gardé
comme un de bons souvenirs de très bons
souvenirs
mais quand j'y retourne de temps en
temps en somme vous passez votre temps
entre paris et les états unis n'ont
nenon j'habite paris mais enfin il
m'arrive de dia les temps en temps faire
une télévision ou un film
alors j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
c'était un premier roman passionnant à
un autre oui oui j'ai même j'en ai même
plusieurs autres ont entre eux
patientent en préparation dont vous avez
commencé l'écriture
oui comme ça un peu au hasard en soit
c'est quelqu'un de très c'est une
nouvelle expérience pour vous c'est une
nouvelle expérience et qui m'amuse
énormément je ne suis plus amusé qu'on
écrive au mont mon autobiographie qui a
paru il ya trois ans parce que large
je tenais à être net et et je ne me
disait rien qui ne sont exacts tandis
que dans un roman on peut laisser aller
le fouet de la satire l'imagination on
peut vagabonder
merci jean pire au monde d'être venu
nous présenter il fait beau mais ne le
répétez pas un roman publié aux éditions
lattès
merci monsieur s'il fait beau à la
bourse de paris vous avez le droit de le
répéter en échos on va le répéter il
fait beau à la bourse de paris jean
pierre pernaut il fait beau grâce à
plusieurs choses il ya plusieurs
secteurs en effet le soleil brille dans
de nombreux compartiments mais en
particulier vous allez le voir tout de
suite au compartiment pétrolier les
valeurs pétrolières sont assez bien
orienté aujourd'hui notamment elf
aquitaine que vous voyez en tête de ce
tableau plus 2,6 pour cent
vous me direz qu elle le mérite bien
après la chute régulière des cours
depuis plusieurs semaines mais ça n'est
pas la seule il y en a d'autres et ce au
standard est également en hausse assez
sensible à 289
aujourd'hui et alors là commencent à
circuler les rumeurs incontrôlable que
l'on connaît bien sur ce marché
pétrolier toujours sensible aux
événements extérieurs et de recherche
pétrolière sans qu'on ait pour autant
d'informations donc un premier secteur
relativement bien orientées y compris
d'ailleurs dans le secteur étrangers
vous voyez petrofina et royal dutch sont
également en hausse mais ce n'est ce ne
sont pas les seuls euros ce que l'on
peut observer aujourd'hui parmi les
valeurs françaises
à la bourse de paris vous en voyez ici
vous retrouvez bien sûr les pétrolières
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres dans le
secteur du sucre par exemple avec
saint-louis bouchons et des gains le
sucre monte en ce moment sur le marché
des matières premières et les valeurs
françaises qui s'intéressent à cette
production évidemment en profite
ce ne sont pas les seuls secteurs le
secteur bancaire le crédit commercial de
france sur lequel on a échangé hier 14
1225 action c'est déjà un gros marché
est une fois de plus au plus haut de
l'année petit rectangle vert pour vous
l'indiquez 182 après 180 d'autres
sociétés du groupe bancaire sont en
hausse aujourd'hui tels que la compagnie
bancaire le crédit foncier immobilier
qu'il faudrait qui reprend en quelque
sorte de la hauteur puisqu'il avait
perdu du terrain les jours précédents la
bct midland bank
et puis il y a également dans le domaine
des matériaux matériaux de construction
avec lafarge et ciments français alors
pourquoi toutes ces hausses aujourd'hui
à la bourse de paris vous le disais tout
à l'heure pour plusieurs raisons d'une
part les sicap monory sont amenés à
acheter un petit peu en ce moment
compléter leur portefeuille vous savez
qu'elles doivent détenir 60% leur actif
un valeurs françaises et il y a un peu
d'argent les cours n'étaient pas trop
chaise avait même baissé par certains
endroits donc il faut acheter un peu
d'action française et puis il ya une
autre raison c'est probablement les taux
d'intérêt on craignait une reprise aux
etats-unis nous semble que cela se tasse
un peu et que l'allemagne soit peut être
amené dans les semaines qui vont suivre
abaisser ses propres taux d'intérêt
compte tenu du mauvais climat
conjoncturel qui règne là bas les
valeurs allemandes dans le groupe
étranger ne sont pas particulièrement
bien orientées ni trop faible en dehors
de siemens ce que vous voyez ici qui
perd 0 3% à 647 à la quatrième ligne de
cotation
les valeurs américaines elles sont un
petit peu plus faible aujourd'hui compte
tenu de la baisse du dollar qui se
poursuit sur les marchés des changes et
les mines d'or sont également du moins
pour certaines d'entre elles est la plus
grande partie en baisse dans la mesure
où l'or sur le marché international a
continué de baisser vous allez le voir
maintenant sur votre écran le dos là à
vous le voyez à quatre fronts 10 40
contre 4 france 62 et l'once d'or fin a
reperdu de dollars à 628 $ 50 ce n'est
tout de même pas dramatique après
l'annoncé par le gouvernement
demant canadien qu'il autorisait la
banque centrale du canada à vendre dans
les semaines ou dans les mois qui vont
venir de nouveau un million d'onces sur
le marché libre de l'or la barre a perdu
13 cents francs à 84 mille francs et le
cumul la baisse de l'or et la baisse du
dollar le kilo lui aussi à borden 14 150
francs le napoléon résiste davantage
mais vous voyez que l'emprunt quatre
ennemis pour 173 lui est en baisse de 46
francs aujourd'hui il avait beaucoup
monté vous vous en souvenez ces deux
derniers jours ces trois derniers jours
et le 7 pour cent soixante-treize qui
lui avait beaucoup baissé se ressaisit
et gagne aujourd'hui 72 francs à cette
1875 et dans les secteurs des emprunts
indexés
nous retrouvons encore la caisse
nationale de l'énergie en hausse de 12
francs aujourd'hui à 3740 après un
premier cours de 3743 donc une bonne
séance
ici aujourd'hui ici la bourse de paris
avoue jean-pierre terme merci rené
tendront fin de ce journal bon courage
ou bonne bronze est pour cet après midi
ce soir 20 heures dominique baudis et
moi je vous retrouve demain à 13h au
revoir